america is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
i was going to put him
excuse me
hey everybody i'm dave rubin or the
artist formerly known as the guy that
was once on twitter dave rubin this is
the reuben report it is july 5th one day
after we celebrated america's birth the
anniversary of the united states of
america 246 years old and she's looking
pretty good despite what these people
are doing to her and yes what you have
heard
probably is true i am now suspended
on
twitter
that's it i've been suspended i'll get
to why i was suspended in just a moment
but let's just do some clerical stuff up
top because i am now suspended on
twitter uh i am on truth social you can
follow me at dave rubin you can follow
the show at ruben report uh and you know
i often start these shows
by reminding you guys to subscribe and
it's like whatever you're watching this
on hopefully you're watching on rumble
or on blaze right now uh because those
are my networks that obviously i'm
partnered with and i have confidence
that they're not going to wipe us away
but you know we know we're on borrowed
time
here at youtube for the same reasons
that i'm now suspended on twitter so if
you have not subscribed to our rumble
channel it's just rumble.com reuben
report please do
as always subscribe to the blaze you get
many other shows than just this one and
man it's just the war
to fight the big tech machine has been
ramped up and i guess i'm one of the
guys that are in the thick of it and as
always of course you know i did start a
tech company
called locals and you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and play along
all right so that's just some of the
technical stuff uh but look all of this
stuff could just go away right if you're
watching on youtube this could just be
gone tomorrow uh the 1.3 million people
that follow me on twitter i can't
communicate with them right now but i
can do it on locals i can do it on
rumble we have to build a parallel
economy all of the things that i've been
talking about for years they're real i
don't even need to make this about me
exactly they blow up all sorts of
people's accounts all the time we know
that they censor and shadow ban and do
all sorts of algorithmic tricks uh and
as i often say it's not the stuff that i
know that they're doing that i'm worried
about it's the stuff that i don't know
that they're doing that i'm really
worried about so why did i get suspended
the day after we declared our
independence ironically this happened at
3am last night so just after
july 4th these twitter freaks what did
they do well here's the image this is
the email i woke up to this morning
i have violated their rules against
hateful conduct and what are those rules
you may not promote violence against
threaten or harass other people on the
basis of race ethnicity national origin
sexual orientation
gender gender identity religious
affiliation age disability or serious
disease now
that doesn't sound like something that
dave rubin would do i poke fun at people
i make fun of people but i certainly
don't instigate violence or really go
after people for their immutable
characteristics so what is it that i
tweeted i must have done something so
horrific and so out of character that
would have brought upon this this just
damning condemnation of what i am and
what i do what was my tweet
uh the tweet was uh this the insanity
continues at twitter jordan peterson has
been suspended for this tweet about
ellen page he just told me he will never
delete the tweet paging elon musk and
what i did there was screenshot jordan's
jordan peterson's tweet about ellen page
now ellen page
was an actress who i suppose is now an
actor named elliot page you may remember
i don't know of any work that elliot
page has done am i missing any big
movies that elliot page has done but
ellen page used to be an x-men and she
was pretty good she she i think i can
say ellen page was in x-men and she was
pretty good she was a she at the time
anyway all i did was screenshot
and comment on jordan being suspended
now ironically here's where this is why
this is all
sort of so mangled in the way they do
everything this tweet that i sent this
defense of jordan was from a week ago
because he got suspended about a week
ago you may remember we talked about it
on the show and jordan put up a pretty
spectacular video on his youtube channel
explaining why he will not delete that
tweet um so what's interesting here is
about a week ago i post that now all
week long i was getting warnings from
twitter that i had uh been reported to
the german authorities and all sorts of
stuff so the the trans activists the
woke wackadoodles they were mass
reporting my account trying to get me
suspended and then suddenly at three am
right after july fourth suddenly i get
suspended i did issue a a statement on
locals because i do have an ability to
get my message out even if i am not on
twitter so i want to read my statement
to you and then i want to give some
props to some of the people that are
defending me right now here's my uh
response this is my official statement
this is dave rubin reading dave rubin's
official statement about his twitter
suspension i have been suspended by
twitter for posting a screenshot of
jordan peterson's tweet tweet which got
he himself suspended while it is unclear
how i broke their terms of service it is
clear that they are breaking their
fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders by letting a bunch of woke
activists run the company i hope elon
musk's purchase of twitter goes through
so he can blow up their servers and
humanity can move past this pervasive
twisted self-imposed mental institution
in the meantime you can find me at
rubinreport.locals.com the platform i
created to fight big tech censorship
something we need now more than ever uh
let me give uh some props publicly to a
few of the people defending me because
you know one of the things and this is
maybe the real bumper sticker of all of
this it's not about ellen page or elliot
page and it's not about misgendering
someone and or anything like that what
this is really about is how fear spreads
right because if you say something
that's true but then you know that
facebook or instagram or twitter can
take you out for it uh you might be less
willing to say something true right if
you get suspended once then maybe the
second time you're going to be like i'm
just not going to say the true thing so
what happens is when they suspend jordan
peterson
only a for saying something true only a
certain amount of people are willing to
say oh i'll defend him i'll post the
screenshot i'll say he shouldn't be
suspended because they don't want to get
suspended right so i think it is worthy
of crediting some of the people uh who
are defending me right now because
you're not just you're not defending me
i don't mean to make this about me what
you're defending is the ability for
truth to be said in in the public square
as we have it in 2022 so ben shapiro uh
who's been nothing but an all-star in
this fight against this woke nonsense he
says reuben report has now been
suspended for posting news about jordan
peterson's suspension all because we are
not allowed to mention that until five
minutes ago elliott page who is very
very very male was a female actress
named ellen page here's dave's statement
a couple other people real quick on this
uh who else we have there tim poole holy
[ __ ] reuben report was suspended for
uh posting about jordan peterson getting
suspended how did he even break any
rules uh and then douglas murray who is
just the perfect british author so ruben
report has been suspended from twitter
for commenting on jordan peterson being
suspended from twitter does twitter
intend to have a future also could it
could it explain whether elliott was
ever ellen
or caitlyn was ever
bruce and then jack posobiac also uh
ruben report has been suspended from
twitter for defending jordan peterson
and a whole bunch of my my florida
freedom fighters josh hammer carol
markowitz uh john cardillo david boy uh
all jumped in on it many other people
anyway
again i don't mean to make this about me
i don't really even mean to make this
about
elliot page or ellen page or any of that
it is the new thing that you cannot say
you cannot say something true there are
biological differences between males and
females if you dead name someone i would
not i honestly would not even and i
don't even want to say this because i
don't want to play by their rules but i
would not know how to refer
to who did she play in uh x-men
she was
who is she in x-men helen page and x-men
was a good character i like those movies
i liked all those x-men movies they're
jumping back and forth between time who
did she play what was the name of the
character whoever it was the point is
that how would i refer to her as oh i
liked that character right i liked that
character kitty pride was her name but
who is the they they she had a name like
an x-man name
shadow what
shadow girl
shadow cat
ellen page was shadow cat anyway doesn't
matter the point is i like the x-men
movies i thought she was good in them
but now do i have to say oh elliot page
was a woman named ellen page and played
a woman named kitty pride in x-men but
i'm not a biologist so are they even
x-men
also [ __ ] stupid bunch of morons
anyway jordan peterson has said he will
not
delete his tweet regarding this whole
incident uh and i have to decide what i
want to do you know i'm all about
building new things i'm all i would love
to cause these things to now implode
from the inside these companies don't
deserve our attention they're
manipulating us in crazy ways perhaps we
all should have risen up uh more so when
they when they took out donald trump and
when they took out a whole bunch of
other people
when they hid the hunter biden story
think of the way they are manipulating
us in crazy ways guys crazy ways crazy
crazy crazy real crazy ways her name was
kitty pride
ellen page in x-men
it wasn't like mysterio or
a girl with she could do some stuff
oh i'm thinking of the other girl who
could touch you and kill you i'm
thinking of that girl you're rogue i'm
thinking a rogue she wasn't rogue okay
fair enough you know all about rogue
okay
anyway what are we doing today well
we're going to talk about some of the
stuff that you're not allowed to talk
about and if you do talk about they say
you hate women or you hate minorities or
a whole bunch of other stuff oh and i
guess i just glossed over
july 4th i hope you had a great freaking
weekend i hope you ate hot dogs i hope
you ate burgers i hope you were with
family i hope you drank some beer i hope
you celebrated and late and and watched
some fireworks and just for a moment
appreciated the glory of
246 years of extraordinary freedom that
people far better than me and you fought
and died for so that woke idiots over at
twitter could ban people from saying
things that are absolutely true and that
is the fight that is on our doorstep
doorstep we had people who have fought
in wars to push back against
authoritarian kings and socialists and
communists and all of that and now we
have to fight a bunch of genderless
wackos running tech companies
i'm up for the challenge are you so what
we're going to talk about today
is uh just some of the general insanity
that's happening uh over the last couple
weeks a lot of it's related to the roe v
wade decision and how the democrats are
now
ready to just burn the whole freaking
thing down how joe biden is just
completely imploding right in front of
our faces and how the liberal new world
order that's their words that's what
they're calling it uh is uh in danger
right now and maybe we need to push it
over the edge so that's what we are
gonna do today
and if i am completely banned off all of
the digital devices if they put some
sort of
virus in my phone that blows up so i can
never use it again which sounds like a
pure freaking joy uh you can see me on
july 14th at the miami improv with
christina pusha and perhaps some other
famous floridians daverubin.com
events if you want to join me real quick
let's talk about real estate agents i
trust and then let's get to it damn
these twitter freaks you know buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment that's a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents
their team makes the introduction and
then follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
the process is simple just go to real
estate agents i trust dot com today and
provide them with some basic info their
team will contact you to make an
introduction to their preferred agent in
your town and now back to me uh let me
just say one other thing real quick
about this uh twitter suspension um i i
don't know what i'm gonna do whether i'm
gonna delete it or or not i have to
decide what i want to do and sort of you
just have to think about all your
decisions i did nothing wrong i didn't
instigate hate there is a [ __ ] ton of
hate directed at me every freaking day
on twitter i don't sit here bitching and
moaning and complaining about it if you
don't want to be on these things you
don't have to what i will just say is
this though if you have not this is one
more plea for you guys if you have not
please do join us at
reubenreport.locals.com we have an ios
app we have a google play app for
android or you can go on desktop it's
free to join you can throw in a couple
bucks if you want to interact a little
bit more get stuff early but in if you
join that way whenever i get booted off
all of these things which seemingly will
happen right anyone with any flicker of
individual thought is going to be booted
off all these things or they will just
depress your views and your reach to the
point of of oblivion right uh so you can
join absolutely free and that way i can
send you messages i can get push
notifications to you and a whole bunch
more so you'll be able to at least track
me when i'm sent out into the nether
region so rubenreport.locals.com
okay so let's talk about what's going on
in the world outside of the twitter
sphere because things are
a little nutty um the left-wing media
they're a bunch of nut jobs and they've
decided to go all in on this abortion
lunacy here we go
there are no more black robes i think
the robes are red and blue there really
is
a lot of people who believe this is a
rigged court a legal earthquake the
court stripping women of that
fundamental right abortion is now a
matter for the states and congress
rather than between a woman will die
because of this ruling 48 of the women
now live in red states so you're talking
about the fact that those state
legislatures at least the court of the
supreme court
the women in those states are their
property and they can
okay that is a small compilation of just
some of the things that are being said
on mainstream media right now related to
this rogue decision now as you guys know
so i don't want to belabor the point but
as you know uh abortion is not illegal
because of this decision it is just
kicked back to the states that actually
i know it's hard for a lot of people to
believe it but that's actually more
freedom because that's the state getting
less involved and if you live in a state
that is not in line with whatever your
views on abortion are whether you love
abortion or hate abortion you can get up
and go somewhere else and you can have
abortions in other states or not have
them in other states etc etc so this is
a beautiful thing that is happening is
it sort of messy and politically
dangerous
it is obviously but there is a full on
assault on the courts right now that's
what this is much more about the supreme
court is being assaulted it is one of
the three branches of government it is
the branch that actually has to look at
the founding documents it has to look
what's on the paper and go hey what's on
the paper is this stuff legal is this
how it works and what is in our purview
to actually make decisions about and are
some things not in our purview for
example
is abortion in the constitution so that
it's a constitutional right oh no it's
not now there are things about equality
treating people equal under the law et
cetera et cetera and there but abortion
is not there uh but the hypocrisy from
the media and the fear-mongering right
that's all it's all just fear-mongering
no one is coming for women no one wants
to make them look like uh dress in those
red
outfits with the white hats like in
handmade tail nobody is doing any of
this stuff but these people are are
larping live-action role-playing
pretending that this is happening in
their lives probably because they're
having some deep existential crisis and
should find god but putting that aside
for just a moment here's health and
homeland secretary xavier becerra
claiming that abortion is a threat
to the fastest route
is to reinstitute that right that women
had until
five justices on the supreme court
decided to use their authority in ways
that deny
millions of americans the right to good
health and perhaps even their life
there's nothing like abortion for good
health right nothing like ripping out a
six-month baby from the woman's stomach
and killing it for good health now again
he keeps saying everything they say is
based on a lie and i think what's
happened now is the democrats in the
mainstream media they lie about
everything everything everything there
is nothing they don't lie about
literally nothing and i mean literally
literally they are so deep in all of
their lies about absolutely everything
that all they can do is lie more and
more so when they keep saying they're
coming for your right to an abortion no
such right exists
and they are saying it's going this is
going to harm life so protecting life is
harming life in their
purview right like it's just completely
insane of course joe biden is the one in
charge of this administration apparently
and you know when they put him out there
and they don't put him out there that
often he usually mumbles through
sentences slurs words and then
occasionally says something that he sort
of thinks is true or he used to think is
true and then they're not happy with him
because he kind of said something that
sort of made sense it happens every now
and again including this past weekend
so the idea that we're going to make a
judgment
that
is going to say that
no one can make the judgment to choose
to
abort a child
based on a decision by the supreme court
i think goes way overboard
now first off note how many words he
says to just get a simple sentence out i
mean there is something cognitively
wrong with him it just is it just is i
know we're not allowed to say it and
it'll probably be double suspended for
saying it but it just is but what's
interesting there is he says he admits
that you are aborting a child now if you
are aborting a child you are aborting a
life now it is the democrats and the
position of the progressives and
virtually all of the mainstream media
that is in essence at this point saying
that an eight-month pregnancy is not a
life it you are allowed to kill that
baby you're also allowed to do
post-birth abortions and a whole bunch
of other seriously dystopian twisted
horror movie stuff that's what they are
saying but joe biden kind of just
mumbled it out he mumbled out what we
all know is true which is that if you
have an abortion you are obviously
killing a child that obviously is true
now that was joe biden this past weekend
here's joe biden back in 2015.
you know there's even been the
disagreement in our church
not that abortion is always wrong
oh
abortion is always wrong
joe biden did you know that
but he's a good catholic don't forget he
is a good catholic but you know as i
said sometimes he just mumbles out these
things sometimes he's off the prompter
sometimes he's on the prompter and also
screws up because he does not know what
he's doing uh here's he seems to be some
con there's some confusion related to
biology here help me out with this one
and politicians invading the most
personal decisions that
not only women but we'll find if they
expend expand on
on this decision uh
men as well
okay so i'm not even sure what he said
there it was some sort of muddled mess
but i think maybe the implication was
that men have abortions or they're going
to expand on this decision and it's
gonna go after men or was he defending
uh the aborted babies that some of them
are male could it have possibly been
that i'm not sure but anyway i i play
all of this to sort of show you that
there's just like this
confused
lie infested
rat hole and out of that comes the
democrats comes the mainstream media and
everything else and then of course comes
the cultural part of this it leaks into
what gets on television who your
comedians are etcetera etcetera
and what they have to do always is not
just lie about everything and tell you
they're protecting life while they're
killing life but they have to they also
have to scare the hell out of you they
have to make sure that you know that
you're a racist and a bigot and an evil
person and that they're literally going
to come to the restaurants where you eat
i can't describe how painful it is to be
here now in a place where the supreme
court has the power to erase 50 years of
constitutional law make no mistake this
is not where it ends conservatives will
not rest until they have come for all of
our rights everything we have fought for
could be lost unless we take it back
it's not just about voting in november
it's about doing everything in our power
to protect and help vulnerable people
access abortion across state lines and
we have to raise hell in our cities in
washington in every restaurant just as
elito eats at for the rest of his life
because if republicans have made our
lives hell it's time to return the favor
so that is samantha bee she was formerly
of the daily show i think she has a show
on tbs or comedy central or something
i'm not sure where she's doing that show
from nobody is watching any of these
shows that's just how it is oh i guess
she her show now moved to hbo max or
something i mean that's one of the
things that happens with these people if
you just give the system what it wants
if you're sort of like a brian stelter
type you just repeat all the talking
points of the system the system will
just keep rewarding you even if nobody's
watching any of your shows it'll just
keep giving you more and more money and
then your shows will be canceled
speaking of the daily show jon stewart
what happened he leaves the daily show
and then he gets this i think apple tv
show right where they paid him probably
10 million dollars a year he goes full
woke and then they get rid of him it's
like you're you're a useful tool to the
system you're just you're bantha fodder
how about that i haven't done a star
wars reference in a while uh that's what
you are you freaks anyway uh what she's
saying there and i don't know that
anyone's watching her show she also has
probably 20 writers on that show uh i
got these three fools in here no offense
guys but you know what i'm saying that
was that was a little offensive great
people but you know what i mean you know
you're not hollywood trained writers
that's all i'm saying thank god i'd fire
you if you were anyway what she's saying
there is
that you should follow samuel alito to
where he eats that here is a man who did
his job first off she's also saying that
they've erased 50 years
of law and it's like no they made a
decision in 1973 that the justices now
decided was not constitutional so the
justice this was the problem with roe v
wade in the first place in 1973 when the
justices looked at it they said oh there
is a constitutional right to an abortion
except it's not in the constitution
again there are things that are actually
in the constitution there are things
that are in the bill of rights that are
actually codified that's a new word
everyone's using right now codified into
law if they were making decisions that
were in conflict with written law then
we'd have a real problem on our hands
but they looked at it they said wait a
minute abortion the right to an abortion
is not in the constitution thus
we must give it back to the states
because things that are not in the
constitution should be given back to the
states that's what federalism is that's
the basic point of the whole freaking
system that's how it is supposed to work
so the system is working right now but
they don't want the system to work
because they want to own you they want
one as i keep saying they want one ring
to control them all they want one power
to control everybody so someone like
samantha b not only is she lying she
either is lying i don't believe she
doesn't know what she's talking about so
she's blatantly lying she's obviously
not funny i don't know who's watching
any of that stuff but she's also ramping
up and this is what they want and
they've been doing it for a long time
ramping up that you should get in their
faces remember maxine waters don't let
them have any peace aoc this is what
ilhan omar does this is what democrats
do all the time they're allowed to
overtake federal buildings go see what's
going on in wisconsin they're allowed to
burn down cities go to any blue state
they're allowed to do all of these
things but when they do it it's somehow
thought of as nice and it's nice and
pleasant destruction when they destroy
the nail salon
by the korean immigrant
they're doing it in the name of black
lives matter they're better than you
that's what they are but their
radicalism is not only bleeding into
culture but also into governance and you
as a free citizen in this country this
is where you're going to be able to
fight back if you vote in the right
people so we can get rid of these clowns
uh so aoc
uh who is a congresswoman she is a
complete
uh
she is what she is okay and i will give
her credit in that she has somehow
become a media
darling right
she may be an idiot she may have no
qualifications to do this but she is
someone that people pay attention to
i believe at this point she is in her
complete uh a complete violation of her
oath of office as most democrats are at
this point i don't know that anything
can be done about that but these people
they swear
to defend the constitution of the united
states and yet the democrats spend most
of their time trying to shred the
constitution much like
nancy pelosi remember when she shred the
papers behind donald trump after that
state of the union that's what they
mostly do most of what the democrats
talk about is how to destroy
the constitution
here's aoc i personally believe that
clarence thomas should be impeached
beyond a shadow of a doubt i am
astonished that
this is a position that is in any way
controversial to anyone the degree and
extent of misconduct
that clarence thomas alone um in
addition to some several of his
colleagues
have participated and engaged in is d
legitim foundationally delegitimizing to
the supreme court and it is our
responsibility our constitutional duty
to reign
them in
so nothing she said there has any
meaning whatsoever notice she didn't get
into any of the legal arguments
that clarence thomas made or samuel
alito made or anyone else made it's just
her feelings about this she's not happy
with his decisions and she should
impeach him or she should pack the court
so that the court can no longer function
so the court will act as a branch of the
legislative
branch you understand that uh so she she
is just a complete
buffoon but it's sore but the media
loves it
the media loves an assault on all of the
systems the media loves watching our
institutions burn and the democrats love
watching the institutions burn because
without a system of checks and balances
if we didn't have
a judicial branch that could look at
what the legislative branch is doing and
an executive branch that could sign
things into laws and that these things
could all fight it out and argue over
each other if we if we could actually
destroy that if aoc could do what she
wants impeach judges who don't make
decisions the way she wants them to or
pack courts so that the branch itself
cannot operate as an independent as an
independent branch of government but
just as sort of this like secondary
legislative branch then what would
happen well you'd have one power one
power that would control everything
that's all progressives want you have to
forget the gender nonsense and critical
race theory and all of those things
they're important to talk about they're
important to identify but what does it
all lead to
it all leads to their power more and
more power for them so speaking of power
here's a fake native american woman
named elizabeth warren and she wants to
end the filibuster
because that would give her more yeah
you guessed it power
two senators if we pick up two
democratic senators who will help us get
rid of the filibuster which the
president has now said he's on board for
that
and who will give us roe versus wade
two senators and yes john fetterman i am
looking at you in pennsylvania yes
mandela barnes i'm looking at you
now look i don't know why you would
listen to a fake native american woman a
woman who pretended to be native
americans so that she could get a job
she is now a hero of the woke of the
progressives this is a woman who is
worth millions and how much is she worth
millions and millions of dollars no
doubt uh millions and millions of
dollars she constantly is demanding that
you send your kids to public school
while she sends her kids to private
school she's a fraud of the highest
level whatsoever she has become worth
millions and millions of dollars oh 67
million dollars she is a socialist
communist who is worth 67
million dollars these people they don't
even hide the fraud they don't even hide
it it is right in your face but what she
wants is she wants more democrats so
they can crush and destroy the judicial
branch okay that is what she is telling
you that she wants and she's not only
telling you that that fake native
american woman uh but joe biden is also
saying that he would like to do that
most important thing to be clear about
is we have to change i believe we have
to codify
roe v wade in the law and the way to do
that is to make sure the congress votes
to do that and if the filibuster gets in
the way it's like voting rights it
should be we provide an exception for
this
except the
requiring exception of the filibuster
for this action to deal with the supreme
court decision
okay mumbling stumbling buffoon joe
biden it's just it's just incredible
that we're all pretending that this
guy's running the country it's
absolutely incredible uh interestingly
uh in
2005 now joe biden's been a part of
public life for roughly 280 years that's
longer than the country has been here
but in 2005
he did not want to end the filibuster
i'm shocked
and we should make no mistake
this nuclear option is ultimately an
example of the arrogance of power
it is a fundamental power grab
by
the majority party
a fundamental power grab but joe that's
what you're doing right now that's what
aoc and elizabeth warren want to do why
would you guys want a fundamental power
grab you guys are the good guys you're
for the people
oh you're not going to believe this guys
we found video of democrats over the
years defending the filibuster they want
to make this country into a banana
republic where if you don't get your way
you change the rules the legislative
filibuster should stay there and i i
will personally resist efforts to get
rid of them i'm committed to never
voting to change the legislative
filibuster that would be the end of the
senate it grazes problems that are more
damaging than the problems exist you
cannot change the rules
in the middle of the game because you do
not like the outcome you're going to
throw the entire congress into chaos and
nothing will get done change the rules
in midstream
to wash away 200 years of history
nothing at all will get done ideologues
in the senate
want to turn what the founding fathers
called the cooling saucer of democracy
into the rubber stamp of dictatorship if
you don't have 60 votes yet it just
means you haven't done enough advocacy
and you need to work a lot harder
you really need to understand these are
horrible human beings there's no other
way to put it i don't think they should
be j well some of them probably should
be jailed cause i'm sure they're up to
illegal stuff but i don't think that we
should show up at their houses i don't
think we should be publicly intimidating
them or anything else what we should be
doing is obviously exposing their
hypocrisy we should be mocking them we
should be voting them out of office but
you need to understand they will do
anything for power it does not mean that
republicans are so great republicans
fail all the time and there's an awful
lot of pet republicans out there the liz
cheney's mitt romney's okay they go on
msnbc they get pat pet on the head and
they get a feta cookie or something
republicans do things wrong all the time
they blow up budgets all of that stuff
but
at least within the sort of roughly
conservative republican
libertarian worldview there is a sense
of limiting power there is a sense of
individual rights the basic quest there
on that right side of the aisle is we we
all are different we want to limit power
to some degree they may fail at it most
of the time but at least there is a
guiding principle there somewhere right
and the government should not do
everything these people want the
government to do every freaking thing
possible and it's because they're in
power and they don't want to give up
that power it's almost as if they have
some sort of liberal new world order
that they're protecting at all costs
what do you say to those families who
say listen we can't afford to pay 485 a
gallon for months if not years this is
just not sustainable
what you heard from the president today
was a clear articulation of the stakes
this is about the future of the liberal
world order and we have to stand firm
what
okay now that's biden's economic advisor
who of course happens to be a former
blackrock executive
surprise surprise i know it's wild the
way these people bounce around in these
things um but what somehow if we're not
at war with ukraine or giving them a
whole bunch of money or just you know
writing a blank check et cetera et
cetera and our gas prices are going up
and our inflation is going up and our
economy is being destroyed if we don't
do that then the liberal world order is
going to collapse
what are they talking about what are
they talking about i don't know what the
hell's going on in ukraine i don't think
we should be given a dime anymore and i
assure you i am not on putin's payroll i
don't think putin is a good guy i don't
think you can just invade sovereign
nations this is ridiculous and by the
way the more that they lie about
everything i think they're doing
something really twisted related to the
ukraine thing right now which is that
it's causing nobody to care at all which
is why i don't really cover it on the
show nobody really cares i care about
the human suffering and i actually know
a few people who've had to flee ukraine
and i'm doing some things on the on the
side to help at least two people
but
but nobody cares because everyone thinks
everything that comes out of this
administration is nonsense no one thinks
giving them 40 billion dollars
unaccounted for but what we have to do
it to defend the new world order
of joe biden and these people well then
that's not a liberal world order that i
want to defend and i'm the freaking guy
who wrote the book on classical
liberalism
uh but the democrats uh sort of do want
to get rid of joe biden that's become
obvious they realize this thing is
untenable that at some point his brain
is going to explode or his eyes going to
pop out of his head or he'll just fall
and break the hip and whatever it is so
now sadly people i have to talk about
california for a second and yes i will
put some money in the jar oh and i want
to make an official statement i want to
make an official statement about the the
california money jar so you know when i
started this when i got to florida the
original idea was i was going to fund
help fund somebody escaping cali a sane
person and moving here to florida and
then a few months ago a bunch of people
were like dave forget that we don't need
more people here we should fund a
democrat to leave florida and go to
california and i kind of like that idea
but i think i've officially decided this
is this is to help someone escape more
than getting rid of someone here it's
like florida's going to be fine but i do
want to help somebody escape i will
select someone from locals and we're
going to give them a couple thousand
bucks at the end of the year and help
you escape california uh if that's the
official uh way we're going to go about
doing this thing and i'm going to put in
another five right now to do that but
the reason i have to talk about
california is because california is run
by a man who was in the movie american
psycho named gavin newsom his wife is
jen siebel newsome
and if her husband didn't kill enough
people in american psycho she's very
excited to welcome all of the nation's
women to come to california to kill
their babies i mean the whole thing is
crazy what is your message to the young
woman in another state who is really
scared right now yeah come to california
i mean
i
i want them to know that we see them we
hear them we're here for them we
recognize their value
come to california we see you we hear
you we're going to take these forceps
and jam them up your vagina and pull out
this seven-month baby and it'll cry for
just a second and then we'll crush its
skull and we'll pay for it and maybe
i'll take you out to lunch we could have
mimosas it would be really great we'll
get an abortion and a mimosa and then
we'll send you back to your red state
ugh you freaks well here's her husband
who is one of the most evil people on
planet earth i would put justin trudeau
up there i would put uh who else who are
the really evil people right now forget
the aocs but you got the justin trudeau
is hitler still around hitler's and
hitler's gone well you got the trudeau
you got the hitler and here's gavin
newsom it's independence day so let's
talk about what's going on in america
freedom is under attack in your state
republican leaders they're banning books
making it harder to vote restricting
speech in classrooms even criminalizing
women and doctors i urge all of you
living in florida to join the fight or
join us in california but we still
believe in freedom freedom of speech
freedom to choose freedom from hate and
the freedom to love don't let them take
your freedom paid for by news and for
california governor
okay so let's be clear about saying
gavin newsom is running for president
he's running for president in 2024 mark
this down date this thing obviously
they're getting rid of biden and they're
going to push new sim out there he is an
evil piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] dirt bag
did i get that right yeah thank you
he's a horrible human being his wife is
a horrible human being everything he
said right there is a complete 180 of
truth i don't know how you can describe
people who who lie as the driving force
in their lives i don't know how you can
describe them as anything other than
pure evil if you believe that the truth
is important you think he gives a [ __ ]
about freedom you think he gives a [ __ ]
about your right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness he has destroyed
california why have 300 000 people fled
california why is florida exploding in
the right sense florida's exploding in
that people are coming here and the
economy is working and everything's
working here
california is exploding because the
cities are burning down what an evil
freak he is he's just horrible but you
can see it happening and that's the
irony gavin newsom he was the mayor of
san francisco but what happens in
progressive politics if you're the mayor
of a city and you destroy a city you
fail up then you become the governor of
the state and then you destroy that
state and you fail up and you'll most
likely be the democrat nominee for
president and god help us all if that
ever happens because he will destroy
whatever is left of this country he is a
bad
bad human being everything he said right
there about florida is a lie everything
he said about ron desantis is a lie
they're not coming for anyone's marriage
is here they're not coming for anyone's
speech here they're trying to defend
children they're trying to get this
neo-racism out of the schools they're
trying to actually accept that
biological reality is real i don't want
to get booted from youtube right now but
boys are different than girls there i
said it
between the twitter band and coffee i
think i'm really feeling it this morning
um here's chuck todd
again msnbc's chuck todd and he's a
democrat obviously but he pretends to be
a journalist but uh he's even starting
to realize the biden thing's breaking
down pretty quick
joe biden is really upset he feels he's
being disrespected feels as if the party
has never there is a little bit of
rodney dangerfield in him you know
they've never really given me respect
and all i do is you know they didn't
want me to run in 15 and look what
happened to in 16. then they they didn't
want me to run in 20 and look what
happened i actually won now they don't
want me to run in 24. do you have a
point
so they're just running cover over there
right because he is a democrat still and
there's kind of run and cover it's like
they know biden's breaking down they
know there is zero guys it's zero white
supremacist zero chance that joe biden
is running again despite what kamala
harris said last week that you saw us
play there's no chance he's running
again he's not even going to make it
most likely to that point uh and
everyone realizes he's breaking down and
oh now he's just being disrespected
they're just disrespect he just what why
should joe biden deserves no respect
look what joe biden has done in a year
and a half to our economy to our supply
chain with his imaginary war in russia
and ukraine everything he has done has
been an abject disaster but thankfully
we've got a black lesbian press
secretary we've got a trans health
person we've got the furry pup person
who's running the nuclear thing
these people are clowns oh and joe biden
his brain is literally melting
god bless america thank you
and god protect our troops
[Music]
did you catch what happened there
jill had to remind him to say god bless
america take a look
god bless america thank you
and god protect our troops
[Music]
yeah he has no freaking idea what he's
doing unbelievable it's so pathetic it's
so absolutely pathetic so what do the
democrats have you know if gavin
newsom's gonna run if joe biden's gonna
collapse well poll project usa has a new
harvard harris poll out on 2024 for the
democrats what a clown claw clown car of
stupidity take a look at this
kamala harris who again was polling at
zero in her own party when biden s
plucked her out of or not biden when the
people in charge plucked her out of
obscurity she's polling at 25
this is all without biden hillary
clinton who's a murderer and a crazy
person 15 bernie sanders the old
millionaire socialist 12 percent gay
pete at 6 percent elizabeth warren who
is worth 67 million dollars while being
a socialist is that six percent aoc uh
is at four percent amy klobuchar who
nobody cares about is that four percent
abrams oh stacy abrams who's done
nothing in her life other than well
she's eaten a lot of hamburgers and
she's also uh she
said that the georgia election results
weren't legit that's her mike bloomberg
three percent which is completely made
up joe manchin at one percent at least
he's a decent dude someone else at six
percent i'd vote for that guy and
undecided at 13 i'd also vote for that
guy although not if they were democrats
uh right before we started the show
michael said that today was going to be
a particularly good show michael what
was your number that you picked
9-6 which is a bold statement out of ten
you said we were gonna do a nine six
conor was freaking out what did you say
you felt there was too much pressure on
me today because of what happened with
twitter you said
eight and a half phoenix what are you
talking about
nine five michael you win today you will
get the guacamole and maybe even
a cookie
later today uh we got a cold clothes for
you in just a second a couple comments
from the locals community anastasia says
this also happened to you during your uh
book launch screw twitter yes i was
suspended one other time on twitter it
was the night before my book launch in
back in july and i was uh suspended for
saying that the vaccines were not
working as promised and that
mandates were coming that federal
mandates were coming both of those
things turned out to be true i was
suspended for that this is exactly why i
created locals i'm particularly
appreciated appreciative of any of you
that follow me on locals and that we get
to uh share our lives together and that
it isn't all about politics and all the
rest of it um because these these
platforms they are doing something so
freaking twisted you know in jordan
peterson's video which if you have not
watched yet his uh explanation of the
elliott ellen page uh
suspension um one of the things he says
is he says maybe i've contributed to
some of this too and i would say the
same thing maybe i've contributed to
some of the craziness there for sure
it's it's it's a toxic platform but it
is the it's the global pr service that
we're all getting information on all day
long right so it is what it is um but
then he said something like maybe i
won't go back on either way like what do
i need it for and i'm sort of feeling
that too it's like maybe we just have to
let these things die the problem
partially though is so jordan's been off
for a week and then at some point people
just stopped talking about it right and
now i could go off for a week and then
they'll stop talking about it and then
it's like you start disappearing from
from the ether in some degree and
there's a little we have to figure out
that part of it but again that's exactly
why i created locals uh jeannie says
they should make a new x-men movie for
trans people x-men
ex men that's funny
that's funny if i could send you
guacamole i would send you guacamole
that was funny paula says dave how was
the july 4th brisket actually so some of
you may know david got me a 17
pound wagyu brisket for my birthday
we did not
do it for
july 4th we did burgers and dogs and a
bunch of that kind of stuff i wanted to
go like a little more traditional
um but uh we will we'll do it maybe for
the uh right before we go off the grid
i'll have my whole crew over and we will
eat lots of smoked meat
ladies and gentlemen if you want to see
me in miami you can go to davereuben.com
events july 14th i will be over there
with christina pusha who is a florida
legend uh as always perhaps more
importantly than ever you can follow me
at
reubenreport.locals.com obviously this
twitter story ain't going anywhere
obviously this mental breakdown story
about joe biden ain't going anywhere
obviously the complete lies of the
democrat party and their media
establishment ain't going anywhere the
culture wars ain't going anywhere and i
ain't going anywhere i will see you
tomorrow
she said i want someone who can bring
some outside energy because i don't
think an insider can beat donald trump
donald trump he's a brilliant guy he
knew what he wanted to do he knew how to
get it done he's brilliant brilliant and
he and he inherited a god-awful
circumstance that's one of the reasons
barack obama picked me as vice president
oh he came along and he always said he
said he said he's entitled to do this he
said you're too old i should want to do
a push-up contest and you talk a lot
about what it means to be a biden and
the integrity that is imbued in that
family name you guys keep saying that
what the hell are you talking about for
hunter biden to be on that board even if
you did nothing wrong the optics weren't
good you know the truth and the fact of
the matter is my son testified and he
was in fact lying it's it's a fact he
lied
he's lying you acknowledge what he said
wasn't even true none of the mainstream
media believes any of that
biden molests another child these are
the things that have been in my
wheelhouse what i've done my whole life
there's plenty of women come on give me
a break here